AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME,
"JURASSIC WORLD" COMMENT
CARDS.
>> "JURASSIC WORLD", WHICH IS A
FUN MOVIE AND YOU SHOULD SEE IT
BECAUSE IT HAS (BLEEP)ING
DINOSAURS. IT HAD THE BIGGEST
BOX OFFICE OPENING EVER THIS
WEEKEND, PROVING THAT WE WILL
NEVER STOP LOVING MOVIES ABOUT
HOW AWESOME IT IS WHEN HUMANS
PLAY GOD AND HOW NOTHING GOES
WRONG WHEN THEY DO.
COMEDIANS YOUR CHALLENGE IS TO
GIVE ME SOME LINES FROM THE
COMMENT CARDS LEFT AT THE
POPULAR TOURIST DESTINATION
JURASSIC WORLD, LIKE IN THE
MOVIE.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, AND GO. MATT LUCAS.
>> I FOUND A 40-POUND DRAGONFLY
IN MY SALAD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> A VELOCIRAPTOR TORE MY
WIFE TO SHREDS.
I WOULD CERTAINLY COME BACK.
>> Chris: DAVE HILL.
>> THIS IS THE CRAZIEST
ANTHROPOLOGIE STORE EVER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
DAVE.
>> LESS DINOSAURS, MORE
CHRIS PRATT, AM I RIGHT OR AM I
RIGHT?
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
MARGARET.
>> NOT ENOUGH VEGETARIAN
OPTIONS IN THE FOOD COURT.
>> Chris: DAVE.
>> NO FEATHERS, DINOSAURS HAVE
FEATHERS.
LOOK IT UP, YOU (BLEEP)TEASE.
>> Chris: POINTS.